ha rhythm games you came into our lives
filled our living rooms with plastic
instruments and then our closets with
fake instruments but the little dog that
started all that was Parappa the rapper
today we are bringing you some gameplay
from the remastered edition on ps4 how
do you guys feel about rhythm games at
this point is it better for them to burn
out or just fade away let us know in the
comments below and be sure to give us a
like and or subscribe for more cheesy
rapping action
[Music]
[Music]
I'm working in the flea market you're
early I've been working your flings my
mama wants a baby just because the
rhythm is slow that don't mean doubt
your count flow in the render in the
snow and the rain up in just about the
funky flow in the end the Ramban discuss
about the funky flow got technically
this webinar song friendly all you ever
needed to be nice and friendly all this
doobie nice sunburn look for you ever
need to be nice and friendly aw strike
it rich the key is love see if everybody
from way above all I can sell a bug up
like this i will try to fill a gap like
this I cancellable booty up like these
problems I relic cats like fit
it's gonna ever year we bring your love
the sky overhead bring Duke luck on your
bum bleep over here
[Music]
the Rhino in the snow and the rain oven
just about the funky boy I gotta [ __ ]
the radar in the snow and the rain up in
the shoulder funky funky flow never
stole everything everything I gave ever
sold everything with everything so
everything everything you have never
thought everything everything mommy
mommy it's all you need funny funny
funny is all you need funny hunny bunny
is all be
a little flea market I will or you will
help me you got that right teacher
thanks a lot